good morning John the year was 2016 when
suddenly everybody started to talk about
dumpster fires a lot we even made a
shirt a 2016 dumpster fire shirt we were
so glad to be leaving that flaming pile
of garbage in the past and then we had
2017 and 2018 and 2019 and oh my God
2020 and then 2021 and 2022 and now
we've had 2023 dumpster fires all the
way down and there are a number of
things that make me very worried about
2024 like very like very
very I am worried that artificial
intelligence will make it even harder
for young people to find a place in the
American economy something that is
already very difficult to do considering
a broad set of policies and systems that
make sure that wealth goes to older
people and not younger people I worried
about a rise in nationalism and nativism
that has made things worse for a lot of
people including increased a lot of
global conflicts that has resulted in
the number of people dying and Wars
increasing for the last 3 years and I'm
fairly certain that it is going to
increase again in 2024 I am certain
unlike a lot of my social media feed for
some reason that Donald Trump will be on
the ballot in November and his mere
existence there is way too close to him
being president again which is
absolutely possible I worried about a
general attack on higher education which
is absolutely enabled by that industry's
inability to control its cost instead of
talking about that we just talk about
culture War nonsense and I'm worried
that the reason that we're doing that is
the exact same reason as why there's
more nationalism which is the complete
disintegration of our media landscape
and I am convinced that that has
happened because platforms like Tik Tok
and Facebook and YouTube are way more
interested in getting people to spend
more time on their platforms than they
are in anything else and the thing that
is most sticky to most people is moral
outrage and I am worried that the people
who are most harmed by any disruption
natural or man-made are the ones who
have the least and I hear far too little
about the cycles that perpetuate
inequality quality both globally and
where I live so like this video is
somewhat inaccurately titled I said that
I was going to be optimistic and that I
have spent more than half of it
discussing why I'm terrified but here
are three optimistic thoughts first I
don't think that we are letting
generative AI have its way with us the
way we did with content platforms with
Facebook and Twitter and YouTube and
even Tik Tok we're just sort of like
yeah do it to me whatever I like it let
it let whatever happens happen at the
beginning of those things there was so
much optimism and very little push back
but the people and companies who
produced the words and the art that
these models were trained on are pushing
back against that in part because they
did not give these companies permission
to train their models on their art and
words I think that's going to slow this
thing down and I think slowing it down
is probably good some people certainly
disagree with me about that but I think
we've had a lot of shocks recently and I
think it'd be good if there were more
time between now at the next big giant
shock thought number two economically uh
this has gone better than than I think
anybody expected like I everybody sort
of at the beginning of last year thought
this was going to be the start of a
pretty big recession and that just
didn't happen the US has had a stronger
economy and labor market than pretty
much any other developed country and
it's also rained in inflation better
than any developed country and I
understand that that doesn't mean that
things are going great for everybody but
the fact that inflation has somewhat
gotten under control means that we can
lower interest rates again which will
encourage investment which hopefully
will mean more homes and it will also
mean more people able to sell their
homes and get new interest rates
somewhere else now that's not going to
fix the housing crisis but it's
directionally correct and thought number
three is the big one and probably the
one I'll get the most push back against
but since 2016 when the dumpster fire
narrative truly began we've been through
two really massive shocks first was the
mass adoption of these many to many
content platforms now I know that that
happened a lot before 2016 I've been on
YouTube since 2007 but there was sort of
a moment when everybody was suddenly
there and a lot of those people were new
to the internet and how it worked and
didn't maybe have some of the defenses
that people who have been here for a
long time have I 100% believe that in
the future we will look back on the
Advent of these content platforms as as
significant a shift as the Advent of the
printing press I might be wrong about
that but in general the biggest shifts
in humanity come along with shifts in
Communications Technologies whether
that's the ability to speak whether
that's storytelling and plays whether
it's radio whether it's the printing
press Revolution and Communications
technologies always lead to societal
upheaval and the second big shock is
that we have been living through a
pandemic that has killed millions of
people has disabled countless others and
that has resulted in a lot of people
spending a lot of time isolated socially
and social isolation is very bad for
people now all that sounds like bad
stuff but here's the optimistic take on
that I think considering those twin
shocks which are huge most people have
actually handled this fairly well like
it's very bad and very intense and yet I
think there's some signs that we might
be healing a bit like for a while it
seemed like the combination of the
social isolation and and fear of other
people plus like the outrage bait of
social media platforms trying to keep
you on them resulted in a fair number of
people in the population thinking that
it was their job to suck this might
sound like a bit of a weird stat to pull
on but in the last year incidents of
disruptive passengers on airplanes went
down 80% I think that might not be a
terrible metric for how Society is doing
as a whole like I think maybe we should
track that along with GDP and meanwhile
a very good sign I think is that people
are posting less they're not leaving
Twitter for Threads they're leaving
Twitter for their group chat with their
friends or they're leaving Twitter to go
for a walk I think almost 10 years on
some immunities might be kicking in here
a little bit now obviously there are a
lot of people still posting through it
but there is some signs that people are
just doing it less people are not very
forgiving of themselves but they are
even less forgiving of of other people
and their species as a whole like here's
a thought that I will often catch myself
having I can't believe that human beings
mammals who evolved to live inside of
small group societies where any loss of
status might literally result in death
are so bad at using many to many content
platforms that have existed for less
than 10 years and are largely optimized
around the whims of like 12 weird guys
in California like brain cut us some
slack we invented agriculture like 5
minutes ago I don't think that I'm
ultimately optimistic about Humanity
like I think we could really go either
way but what I am is forgiving I think
I'm a lot more forgiving of humanity
than most people we are the weirdest
thing in the known universe and like my
least optimistic and most forgiving take
about that is it's very hard to be this
weird John I'll see you on Tuesday
surprise I've clo I'm going to be in
Southern California in a couple of weeks
doing my onean standup comedy cancer
show which is a real thing I'll be in
Oxnard Brea San Diego and downtown Los
Angeles that downtown Los Angeles show
will get recorded and then eventually
released in a way that I cannot yet
discuss but if you're around Southern
California this will be I think the only
times I will ever do this show again so
maybe the last time I'll ever do standup
again because while I love it I don't
think I want to do it professionally
seems like a thing that could definitely
break your brains